el curso escolar inició a principios de
septiembre en varios países del mundo
pero apenas unas semanas después de la
vuelta a las clases varios colegios han
tenido que cerrar sus puertas debido a
los rebrotes de kobe 19 entre
estudiantes y docentes
'israel clausuró sus escuelas de este
jueves antes del segundo confinamiento a
nivel nacional el ipi le grita al sk
empecé el primer grado conocí nuevos
amigos y de repente llega el coronavirus
y tenemos que quedarnos en casa no es
divertido porque quiero estudiar
con el fin de las vacaciones de verano y
ante la llegada del otoño europa está
viviendo una grave segunda ola de
contagios dos semanas después de su
reapertura francia ha cerrado 81
escuelas y 2100 clases por casos
positivos de kobe 19 las autoridades
educativas griegas suspendieron las
clases temporalmente sólo tres días
después del inicio del curso y en españa
los profesores detectaron el cierre de
300 aulas y colegios ante las protestas
de los profesores por la falta de
medidas de seguridad sanitaria efectivas
una situación que tenemos que con que se
llevan a cabo un protocolo que muchas de
nosotras no compartimos pero que además
no tenemos recursos para poder llevarlo
a cabo europa retomó la nueva normalidad
en un intento de incentivar su economía
pero los casos semanales han superado
los reportados cuando la pandemia
alcanzó su punto más álgido en el
continente según alarma la ms